على سكه الحديد باتجاه الاراضي
البيلاروسيه ترسل روسيا المزيد من العده
والعتاد والدبابات والمدرعات في اطار خطط
عسكريه تتضمن تدريبات مشتركه وانتشار اكثر
من تسعه الاف جندي روسي في بيلاروسيا في
سياق التاهب القتالي والتعبئه الجزئيه
التي اعلن عنها الرئيس الروسي لازم البوتن
والتي تقوم على تدريب اكبر عدد ممكن من
الجنود تحسبا للتطورات المقبله على ساحات
المعارك في اوكرانيا
في الوحدات القتاليه بينما هناك اكثر من
80,000 من جنود الاحتياط في منطقه العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه والبقيه هم في مناطق
تدريب
التدريبات الروسيه البيلاروسيه المشتركه
تتضمن مناورات بالذخيره الحيه وتدريبا على
صدها من خلال التركيز على المشاه والقوات
المدرعه واستخدام قوه ناريه كثيفه
التحالف العسكري بين موسكو وميسك جاء حسب
السلطات البيلاروسيه كانت على ما تصفه
بتفاقم الاوضاع على حدودها الغربيه في
اشاره الى بولندا وتحريرها كاف من اي هجوم
يستهدف اراضيها